première minute de cette affaire je dis
que cette accusation est infondée et je
n'ai jamais changé de point de vue sur
ce
sujet cette on voit là le tribunal a dit
non seulement que je n'étais pas en
cause dans cette affaire mais qu'il n'y
avait pas de système qu'il n'y avait pas
d'enrichissement personnel et que donc
tout ce qui a été porté comme accusation
comme
comme mise en cause contre un mouvement
politique était et on le voit bien
aujourd'hui euh sans cause
euh il y a des il y a des décision de
certains députés européens sur un nombre
extrêmement limité de
cas je veux rappeler que on a eu pendant
cette période 150 au moins
contrat de parlementaires européens il y
en a 10 qui sont et partiellement en
cause on voit bien que il y a un
déséquilibre très important mais pour
moi ce qui me ce qui est ce qui me
satisfait c'est que la preuve soit
apportée que non il n'y avait pas une
volonté en quoi que ce soit de
détournement de de fond du Parlement
européen nous qui nous sommes pour
l'Europe tout au long de tout au long de
notre vie maintenant on va on va
regarder les motivations du tribunal
pour moi évidemment
c'est un cauchemar de cette
année qui qui vient de s'achever par une
décision sans contestation du tribunal
et évidemment je pense au gachi que ça
représente au
gachi
politique puisque pendant cette année
nous avons été en fait interdit de
responsabilité je pense au gâi financier
qui est très
important et je pense au gachis humain
et et de tout cela
évidemment la décision du tribunal donne
une lecture qui
est une une
négation de de d'accusation qui durent
depuis des années et des années
l'horizon se dégage cap sur
2027 on verra je je suis pas là pour
réfléchir à de l'avenir politique ou à
de la
politique
c'est après une épreuve de cette ampleur
et de cette dimension de cette longueur
dans le
temps c'est pas la politique qui est le
plus important je sais très bien depuis
le début que jamais je
n'ai commis euh ce dont on nous
accusait je n'ai je n'ai je n'ai jamais
commis depuis le début depuis depuis mon
premier jour d'entrée en politique les
faits sur lesquels on avait bâti une
accusation de de de système
d'organisation de complot de jamais
immédiatement pris à relax vous avez
consulté votre téléphone est-ce que par
hasard vous aurez reçu un message du
chef de l'État est-ce que Cêtre relaxe à
quelques heures de la seconde bague de
pour dire dans le dans le jeu j'ai
consulté mon téléphone pour envoyer un
message à ma femme et à mes enfants sur
la boucle
[Musique]
familiale c'est une affaire qui a
été par ses conséquences
épouvantables
politiquement pour un courant politique
qui est le courant politique sans doute
le plus européen de la vie politique
française pour la probité de ses
membres vous avez noté que le tribunal a
tenu à expliciter qu'il n'y avait eu
aucun enrichissement personnel de qui
que ce soit et le tribunal a tenu à
expliciter c'est très rare qu'un
président de tribunal a a tenu à
démentir l'accusation en disant qu'il
n'y avait jamais eu de système vous
savez c'est c'est mot qu'on avait
utilisé d'une
organisation méthodiquement
pensée pour pour détourner de le
tribunal a dans son jugement dans son
prononcé de jugement tenu à dire qu'il
n'y avait pas de système pas
d'enrichissement personnel pas de
système pas de responsabilité de ma part
je suis pas tout à fait naïf et le
président l'a dit la cible de toute
cette affaire hélas c'était moi gâi le
plus grave c'est un gâi humain parce
que il y a des gens qui on sont morts
est-ce que justement ça ouvre la voix
pour de nouvelles responsabilités pour
vous le problème pas le
problème une des caractéristiques du
métier de journaliste c'est qu'on ne se
contente jamais du présent il faut
toujours qu'on se projette dans l'avenir
alors on va attendre quelques minutes
quelques heures pour réfléchir à cet
avenir moi ce que je vois c'est les se
années qui viennent de s'écouler est-ce
qu'il y avait d'injustice dans ces 7
années est-ce qu'il y a de dur dans un
certain nombre de peines pour des
parlementaires européens dont je sais la
probité et l'absolu alors il est
possible qu'il y ait des parlementaires
européens qui n'ai pas fait travailler
assez leur assistant il y a 20
ans mais est-ce que ça justifie euh 6
semaines de procès 7 années
d'instruction
ils n'ont plus aucun document d'il y a
20 ans et le tribunal l'a dit tout ça
est parfaitement compréhensible moi ce
que je vois c'est le gâi c'est ce que a
coûté à un courant
politique majeur et totalement
désintéressé engagé pour des idéaux pas
seulement pour des intérêts mais pour
des idéaux ce qui a coûté cette affaire
de manière dont on est aujourd'hui
totalement infondé on vous s trèsation
de Mariel de de sarnes qui avait aussi
quitté le gouvernement comme vous en
2017 est-ce que dans les prochaines
heures on pourra vous rappeler monsieur
le ministre écoutez d'abord en France
comme vous savez la coutume qu'on peut
critiquer c'est que si vous avez été
ministre une fois on doit vous appeler
monsieur le ministre toute la vie et je
n'ai jamais attaché la moindre
importance à ce genre de titre ce qui
m'intéresse c'est l'engagement et les
missionsv à disposition du Pr la VI